grandes procesiones bloqueos de
carreteras y enfrentamientos con la
policía
escenas que se han vuelto habituales en
sri lanka en los últimos meses uno de
los motivos de la ira de los
manifestantes la crisis económica la
peor desde la independencia del país
inflación récord aumento de los precios
de los alimentos escasez de gas
electricidad y combustible la situación
es tal que muchas personas dependen
ahora de la madera para sobrevivir
hace tres meses que no tenemos gas antes
lo usábamos para cocinar pero ahora
tenemos que usar fuego de leña la vida
es muy difícil incluso la madera se ha
convertido en algo difícil de encontrar
área la pandemia ha paralizado el sector
turístico que representaba el 10 por
ciento del pib y debilitó una economía
ya inestable soy blanca no paga su deuda
desde el pasado mes de abril según las
naciones unidas casi el 80% de la
población no tiene suficiente para comer
las políticas aplicadas no han dado sus
frutos y según algunos economistas
incluso han empeorado la situación
por ejemplo la súbita prohibición de los
fertilizantes para pasar a la
agricultura ecológica ha provocado una
drástica caída de la producción para
muchos las autoridades son incompetentes
y corruptas
tienen que irse trabajamos un día y
luego pasamos cinco en las colas así que
queremos que se vayan
la corrupción tiene una cara en
particular la de gotabaya rajapaksa
elegido presidente en 2019 jefe de un
clan familiar que ha dominado la
política durante casi 20 años